[Music]
on this sunday night
the debate over vaccinating young people
should the priority be a double dose for
the older population
plus a new british study shows the need
for two doses against the variants
tragedy in italy a popular cable car
crashes on its way to a mountaintop view
and mount near a gongo erupts sending
thousands
fleeing
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada reached a significant
milestone this may long weekend
in less than six months more than 20
million vaccine doses have been given
out across the country
each province and territory is handling
its own rollout
but they're all using a single dose
strategy the idea is to delay second
doses to allow as many people as
possible to have
some immunity but as jeff sample
explains in our top story tonight
some experts say it's now time to change
tactics
ontario's vaccination clinics are
suddenly full
of young faces starting sunday any
ontarian aged
12 and up is eligible to receive their
first dose of a covid19 vaccine
lucas latinville just turned 12 this
month it feels pretty good to know that
i'm safer from covid and it's
a lower chance now excited we could
start our summer right now
feel some freedom right canada is
doubling down
on single doses just over 50 percent of
the population has now received its
first shot
but when it comes to the second dose
canada lags far behind
at just over four percent in ontario
those lucky few who've received a double
dose
include frontline healthcare workers and
residents of long-term care homes
everyone else including seniors and
others with compromised immune systems
will have to wait up to four months
unfortunately
we have to turn some people away because
as you know it's more important to get
the first dose in
maria elena arrived to get her 14 year
old vaccinated
she received her first shot last month
and has an appointment to receive her
second
in mid-august yeah it's very long
infectious disease doctors
agree if you really want to focus on the
most important
numbers during the pandemic which is
hospitalizations and deaths
vaccinating younger people doesn't make
as much sense as giving the second dose
to the elderly individuals
when it comes to the most vulnerable age
group those over 65
a cdc study found a double dose of
pfizer biontech or moderna
was 94 effective at preventing
hospitalization
but for those who'd only received their
first dose that protection dropped
to 64 percent we do know that vaccines
work
less well in individuals who are older
in contrast canadian youth
represent less than two percent of
covid19 hospitalizations
adolescents certainly are at a very low
vanishingly low incidence of severe
illness
so in terms of vaccinating them the
priority is less so than say
an 80 year old in the community who
certainly can get ill
this said the adolescents we are seeing
are a significant source of transmission
at the present time
as canada's vaccine supply soars some
provinces such as manitoba
are beginning to shorten the interval
between shots for some at-risk groups
but as it stands when ontario emerges
from its lengthy lockdown on june 2nd
that older vulnerable population will
still be waiting
for its second dose jeff semple global
news toronto
governments around the world are trying
to strike a balance between prioritizing
first and second doses
the increasing presence of a variant
first detected in india
could affect how those decisions are
made preliminary results of a new
british study suggest
two vaccines used in canada do work well
against the variant
but only when people have both shots
redman shannon explains
india's capital has extended its
lockdown another week
new covert 19 case numbers in the
country are still over
200 000 a day thought to be driven by
the
b1617.2 variant it was first found in
india
and is believed to be more transmissible
it's appearing around the world too
vaccine rollout has been
sped up in parts of england where the
variant has spiked
the hope is that vaccines will stop its
spread
preliminary findings in a new report by
public health england say
that hope is mostly well-founded when
comparing the india variant with the
so-called
uk variant both the pfizer biontec and
astrazeneca vaccines were
nearly as effective at reducing
symptomatic cases
for people who were given two doses but
for those with one dose
effectiveness dropped significantly to
33 percent
the study appears to support england's
decision this month to bring forward
second doses for people over 50 years
old
we all know that the way out of this
pandemic is the vaccine
and this data show that that is not
changed that is the right strategy
but it makes it even more important for
everybody to get the second jab
the low first dose figures and a lack of
data on disease severity and
deaths has some experts concerned that
england's goal of ending all
restrictions on june 21st
may be a little ambitious at the moment
the number of people in hospital
and icu is really very low and
although we have seen a slight uptick in
some of these areas with high levels of
infection from this variant
sadly within the next 10 days two weeks
we'll be much clearer about that
but a first or second dose strategy
isn't a luxury most countries have
out of every 1 000 people in the world
about 150 of them globally have had a
first dozen vaccine
in sub-saharan africa out of a thousand
people eight of them
have had a first dose of a vaccine
experts add the longer some countries
remain
unvaccinated the more likely it is a
variant will appear that may be much
more resistant to any vaccine
ultimately you can't rule out second
doses until you give out the first ones
redmond shannon global news london
the variants of concern appear to be
driving the surge of cases in manitoba
new numbers released today show nearly
60 percent of the province's active
cases
are variants manitoba recorded more than
460 cases in the last 24 hours
the bulk of them in the winnipeg region
the province is also seeing an increase
in hospitalizations
and that's prompted some of the
country's top doctors to speak out
the canadian medical protective agency a
non-profit
governed by physicians from across
canada sent this letter to manitoba's
premier
they're urging the province to
immediately adopt a critical care
triage protocol and to issue an
emergency order to allow for its
implementation
there's concern manitoba's rise in kova
19 cases
could overwhelm hospitals several other
provinces including alberta and quebec
have triage protocols there are signs
tonight
india may have passed the peak of its
devastating second wave
it reported just over 240 000 new
infections today
that's the lowest daily case count in
more than a month
experts hope the spread of cova 19 may
finally be slowing
but there's a new concern black fungus
the life-threatening condition
is now impacting cova 19 patients and
those who recently recovered from the
virus
nucor mycosis is a very rare but very
dangerous disease with a high mortality
of about 50 percent
the range is between 40 and 80 percent
depending on the location of infection
and the underlying condition of the
patient
the fungus can infect any part of the
body
but the face is frequently infected
so far nearly 9 000 cases involving this
fungus have been reported in india it's
not contagious
but doctors say the infection could
further complicate india's fight against
the pandemic the united nations is
launching an
urgent aid appeal for gaza where there
are concerns kova 19 could spread in the
aftermath of israel's 11-day bombardment
airstrikes heavily damaged the building
housing the palestinian territory's only
coven 19 testing facility
the lab resumed testing on thursday
according to the new york times
it processed more than 500 tests in the
first 24 hours
just over 200 came back positive israel
and the militant group hamas are in the
third day
of a ceasefire european nations are
accusing the president of belarus of
state terrorism
alexander lukashenko sent a fighter jet
to force down
a ryanair flight to arrest one of his
biggest critics
the flight from athens to lithuania made
an emergency landing in minsk
and authorities took roman pertusavich
into custody
protosevich is a journalist who
co-founded a channel popular with
opposition supporters
ryanair says air traffic control told
the pilots to divert to the nearest
airport in belarus
because there was a potential security
threat none
was found thousands of people have fled
their homes in the democratic republic
of the congo
to escape the lava erupting from a
volcano
meant near gongo north of the city of
goma is one of the world's most active
volcanoes and among the most
dangerous the lava has already destroyed
at least
500 homes local authorities say five
people died in a car crash while trying
to get out of the area
as jennifer johnson reports neregongo
has devastated the region
before
hundreds of people in eastern congo
awoke sunday to streets covered in lava
homes and buildings destroyed the
volcano's fiery eruption caused
widespread panic in the city of two
million people
thousands of goma residents ran for
their lives fleeing with whatever they
could hold on to
including mattresses everyone is running
away
the massive fireball turned the sky
bright for kilometers
many desperate residents had only small
buckets of water to try and save their
belongings
lava is now close to reaching the city's
airport many streets are impassable
power has been cut off to most of the
city the congolese president is
returning home from europe to help
coordinate relief efforts
officials have launched an evacuation
plan
i asked the population to remain calm
and follow the instructions of the
police
this official said but there was little
calm as this dangerous volcano rained
down its destruction
being cautious as you can see
people with their bugs kids many
residents were upset officials did not
warn them ahead of time
the volcano was about to blow
there's no information this man said
people are panicking
the last time this volcano erupted was
in 2002
that explosion left 250 people dead and
120
000 homeless rwanda's ministry of
emergency management
says at least 3 500 congolese have
crossed the border
and will be lodged in schools and places
of worship
jennifer johnson global news in northern
italy 14 people died including a 10 year
old when a cable car carrying passengers
to a nearby mountain peak
crashed it happened at a popular resort
town near
lake missouri emergency crews face steep
terrain to access the wooded area where
the crumpled car was found
a five-year-old child survived but
required surgery for multiple fractures
local officials say the cable broke when
the car was about 300 meters
from the top of the mountain things took
a tragic turn when extreme weather hit
an ultra marathon race in china
21 runners died saturday during a 100
kilometer race
in high altitudes the day started off
with decent weather
by the afternoon the temperature dropped
and part of the mountain route was hit
with gale force winds
freezing rain and hail the major rescue
effort was launched but conditions
only grew worse public outrage is being
directed at local officials
criticizing them for failing to have
proper contingency plans
coming up the former bbc reporter speaks
out about his interview
with princess diana plus the warmer
waters in the atlantic ocean and the
harm
to marine life
former bbc journalist martin beshear has
broken his silence over that deceitful
interview with princess diana in 1995
when for the first time she revealed her
husband prince charles
was being unfaithful there were three of
us
in this marriage so it was a bit crowded
the princess was referring to camilla in
that bombshell interview
charles went on to marry her in 2005.
beshear says he is deeply sorry and
never wanted to harm princess diana
there are calls for an overhaul of the
bbc following the scandal
i can only imagine the feelings of the
of the royal family
and i hope very much that the bbc will
be taking every possible step to make
sure that nothing like this
ever happens again an investigation
shows that bashir
faked bank statements to suggest palace
staff were being paid for stories about
princess diana
he used that false information to
leverage diana's brother
into arranging a meeting with the
princess
there's new evidence showing just how
quickly our planet is warming
it comes from an update on global
climate information that's being
compiled by meteorologists around the
world
and as ross lord explains when it comes
to the ocean off atlantic canada
the findings show an alarming trend in
the effort to track
climate change researchers are updating
average temperatures around the world
and for the 30-year period ending in
2020 ocean waters on the east coast
are standing out one of those areas
that's warming fastest is along the east
coast of the u.s
into atlantic canada climate change
meteorologist ben
knowl has compiled the information into
a world map
with the fastest warming waters
highlighted in red
like these dark red splotches south of
nova scotia we've seen an increase of
anywhere from about four tenths to six
tenths of a degree
in nova scotia's coastal waters uh but
further
offshore we've seen as much as maybe
eight tenths to a degree celsius
warming he says that increase has
happened in the past 10 years
warmer waters can lead to more
devastating hurricanes
and heavier rains some pockets of the
north atlantic are warming even faster
and it's disrupting marine life lobster
for example
has shifted from southern new england to
more
central new england and nova scotia and
into newfoundland in recent decades
quite rapidly our region has probably
benefited from this because we're at the
center of its distribution currently
another casualty the north atlantic
right whale the endangered whales have
moved further north to replace food
sources that are collapsing from the
warmer waters
they've been killed by cargo ships and
becoming tangled in fishing
gear now the federal government has
imposed regulations to help save them
as marine researchers predict more
upheaval so
we see real large changes in our
ecosystem
and it's no wonder because it is one of
the fastest warming regions in the
planet and we really need to adapt
that change feeling the heat on adapting
to the warmer oceans that surround us
ross lord global news
still ahead accessing government
information
is political meddling creating new
hurdles
you're watching global national
every year ottawa receives about 120 000
requests for records
under the access to information act and
under this law the government can never
know who made the request
but david again has uncovered a case
where the government wasn't accepting
anonymity david well robin back in 2017
then immigration minister john mccallum
was defending a decision
to move about 350 federal government
workers
from a small town in rural alberta to
edmonton
well people in that small town vegeville
alberta were furious
but mccallum said the move would save
the federal government millions of
dollars
but global news received internal
government documents
released as a result of an ati request
that showed the opposite that it would
cost millions more to move jobs
from vegaville to edmonton now global
news has received some
new records via another ati request and
they show that when mccallum's office
saw the original global news story
his staff wanted to find out who made
the request
mino that's government speak for the
minister's office
is urgently looking for the source of
info in the media story about
vegerville can the ati office please run
a search
that was an email written by a senior
immigration official in may 2017
but just obtained this week by global
news
legal experts say the question should
never have been
asked a minister who does that in fact
interferes with the right of access
in some ways is trying to intimidate you
or somebody of your profession
to be asking such questions and it's
illegal it's not
at all allowed for a minister to dig
into who
is getting information out of their
department
legally that's forbidden it's not the
first time that this has happened
stephen harper's pmo once tried to
identify a canadian press reporter
asking for politically sensitive
documents and an aide to one of harper's
ministers
had to resign for meddling in the ati
process
new democrats say that next week they'll
ask parliament's
information commissioner to begin an
investigation
into political interference in the ati
process a process
used by tens of thousands of canadians
every year
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
up next saving the whales there's now an
app for that
we'll explain when global national
returns
dan you might want to just check that
piece just on the underside just to make
sure
that it's all clear of the fossils
it might not look like much to the
untrained eye but researchers in bc are
buzzing over this
84 million year old turtle fossil
the royal bc museum says an amateur
fossil hunter reached out for help
after making the discovery earlier in
april the museum is now working to
identify the turtle species
if it turns out to be new to science
experts say
it could advance our understanding of
prehistoric
marine ecosystems another discovery a
made in british columbia app
is helping researchers better understand
the movements of the whale population on
the west coast
information about their sightings is
important to protect them
from the boat traffic that can be a
deadly threat to these creatures
as linda ellsworth reports the data gets
to vessels
in real time
after over a century of wailing off our
coast
whales are at last making a comeback
it's a real success story
but it does mean that boaters are going
to encounter them more and more over the
next two years
in some ways it's a good thing with the
help of the oceanwise whale report app
boaters are helping researchers by
reporting the location of their
sightings
but marine vessels can also pose a
threat he's having an issue
oh no don't die last year washington
state ferry
struck and killed two humpback whales in
this case
a photographer caught the moment of
impact earlier this month in san diego
an australian destroyer came into port
with two dead endangered fin whales
stuck to its hull
and closer to home this humpback
sustained a deep
gash after being struck near spanish
banks a few weeks ago
it highlights really how important it is
to uh to have a warning system
and to have it available to ships crews
all the time
what most recreational boaters don't
know is that warning system already
exists the same whale report app that
aids research can
also reduce deadly strikes that
information immediately goes to our
computer
and that and our system looks around to
see if there are any
uh users of the rail report system
within 10 nautical miles of that
location
and since the app is widely used by
ferries the coast guard and other large
vessels
many get the warning they need to slow
down and look out
the information is really important and
it really has been very effective in
sort of protecting whales against our
children of course an app alone
isn't enough boaters have a
responsibility to stay
400 meters away from killer whales 100
meters away from
humpbacks and other large baleen whales
when they blow on the surface and go
down you don't really know where they're
going to come up and they can cover a
lot of ground
so got to slow down when that happens
linda ailsworth global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the bulkley
valley near houston bc
we would love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you